[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus
à la une ce soir trois mois après le
début de la guerre en ukraine nous
prendrons des nouvelles des étudiants
africains qui ont dû fuir les combats
des centaines ont trouvé refuge en
allemagne mais vous allez le voir il ne
bénéficie pas du même traitement que les
réfugiés ukrainien
le zimbabwe s'il veut vendre son stock
national d'ivoire laurent blanc qui est
interdit à la vente le pays dispose de
centaines de milliers de tonnes dans ses
coffres ce qui représenterait 600
millions de dollars pour les caisses de
l'état
et puis c'est une autre ressource dont
dispose la république démocratique du
congo des gisements d'hydrocarbures à
des appels d'offres vont être lancés
pour l'exploitation de 16 blocs
pétroliers et didier boudy m'bow
ministre congolais des hydrocarbures
était mon invité
il ya trois mois il quittait
précipitamment l'ukraine l'invasion
russe a stoppé net leurs études dans le
pays soixante dix mille étudiants
étrangers ont dû tout laisser derrière
eux pour fuir les combats trois mille
ont trouvé refuge en allemagne ce sont
en grande majorité des étudiants
africains elle mais contrairement
réfugiés ukrainiens qui ont
immédiatement accès au soutien de l'état
allemand et un permis de séjour les
réfugiés des pays tiers sont laissés
pour compte voyez ce reportage de notre
correspondant à berlin and my est
tous les dimanches il se retrouve dans
ce jardin communautaire à berlin ils
sont réfugiés de la guerre d'ukraine
mais originaires d'états tiers comme
mohamed ce jeune kenyan a fui kiev dès
le 24 février il venait de commencer ses
études de médecine mais contrairement
aux ressortissants ukrainiens en europe
il n'a pas accès à la protection
temporaire qui accorde un droit de
séjour immédiat aux personnes exilées
c'est très dur pour les étudiants
étrangers nous profitons un certain
nombre de privilèges en ukraine on y
faisait de bonnes choses comme étudiée
mais maintenant c'est très dur de
s'installer dans un autre pays européen
soixante dix mille étudiants étrangers
poursuivaient leurs études en ukraine
avant la guerre jusqu'à 3000 d'entre eux
auraient trouvé refuge en allemagne mais
ces derniers elles ont pas accès au
logement ni au marché du travail si les
aides sociales
à berlin ils sont soutenus par plusieurs
organisations qui réclament les mêmes
droits pour tous les réfugiés nantes
c'est un traitement clairement injuste
et pour nous il ne peut pas y avoir de
réfugiés de première et de seconde
le problème est lié à une discrimination
est un racisme structurel ce sont des
gens qui ont vécu exactement la même
chose que les ukrainiens ils ont tout
perdu e dossier mais ici on regarde
avant tout où ils venaient auparavant
une situation administrative précaires
sans perspective d'avenir et la menace
d'une expulsion vers leur pays d'origine
pour ces jeunes étudiants l'incertitude
est difficilement soutenable
nous sommes complètement intégrée dans
la communauté européenne on habite ici
depuis si longtemps qu'on a plus rien
qui nous relie à notre pays d'origine
j'ai l'impression que je vais craquer je
ne suis pas le seul dans cette situation
cela concerne toutes les personnes de
couleur pour l'heure ces étudiants qui
sont majoritairement originaires
d'afrique et du moyen-orient dispose
uniquement d'une autorisation provisoire
de séjour jusqu'au 31 août mais tous
espèrent obtenir bientôt mon visa
étudiant
le rwanda s'apprête à accueillir à les
50 premiers migrants arrivés
illégalement sur le sol britannique
c'est le fruit d'un accord controversé
signé entre kigali et londres ces
migrants pourront être originaires du
monde entier d'irak du pakistan ou
encore d'afghanistan à l'exclusion du
rwanda et de sa région mais ce projet a
suscité la polémique car des orphelins
du génocide des tutsi ont été expulsés
des deux qui leur était réservé pour
faire de la place aux migrants le
reportage de simon wohlfarth
leur post elle est en plein travaux des
migrants expulsés du royaume uni doivent
arriver dans les prochaines semaines
malgré la polémique le manager yvon un
intérêt économique pour lui l'accord
entre kigali et londres est l'occasion
de remplir ses chambres il facturera à
londres 70 euros par jour et par
migrants duale est beau nous pouvons
accueillir 100 personnes dans 50
chambres les migrants auront le droit de
sortir de l'établissement ce n'est pas
une prison c'est une zone de relogement
alors qu'assad celui-là d'importantes
étaient construits en 2014 pour donner
un refuge aux orphelins du génocide des
tutsis dans le besoin une vingtaine
d'entre eux étaient encore lors de
l'annoncé du partenariat avec le royaume
uni
depuis ils ont été sommés de quitter les
lieux
la plupart des orphelins étaient
étudiants nous sommes à l'est l'hôtel
pour trouver refuge pendant nos études
ou non on nous a donné de l'argent pour
partir mais ce n'est pas suffisant pour
couvrir nos besoins sur un an quand il
faut acheter de la nourriture et
d'autres équipes nous allons devoir
revenir à notre misérable ancienne vie
on ne va rien tirer de tout cela demain
je n'aurai plus les moins de payer un
loyer je retournerai dans la brousse là
où je survivais avant de venir dans cet
hôtel
de son côté le gouvernement nie toute
expulsion de l'hôtel et considère que
ces étudiants doivent prendre leur
indépendance
les autorités se disent prêtes à
accueillir 500 migrants sur trois sites
hôteliers de qualité une capacité qui
devrait continuer d'augmenter cet
accueil / apportant temporaire au
programme et très bien clair les gens
doivent certainement vivre avec les
rangs des dons qu'ils sont là bas pour
savoir qui migrants qui est réfugié qui
je retournais chez lui après cette
procédure il faudrait que ils soient
disséminés parmi la population le ronde
a déjà accueilli des personnes évacuées
de libye dans le cadre d'un accord signé
avec le haut commissariat pour les
réfugiés et l'union africaine
celui passé avec le royaume uni sera
entièrement financée par le contribuable
britannique
le pays a annoncé débourser 144 millions
d'euros dans un premier temps
on l'appelle l'or blanc l'ivoire des
éléphants est interdit à la vente depuis
1989 alors les stocks s'accumulent au
zimbabwe plusieurs milliers de tonnes
qui représente potentiellement une manne
de 600 millions de dollars art et
souhaitent pouvoir les mettre en vente
les explications de charlie sitbon
le zimbabwe a saisi tellement de
défenses d'éléphants qu'il ne sait plus
quoi en faire enfin si il aimerait les
vendre bien entendu le commerce d'ivoire
est interdite puisqu'il encourage le
braconnage
harare demande une dérogation
exceptionnelle
on le voit rien de bien enfin rien de
mal à faire une telle vente surtout en
cette période difficile due qu'aux vie
de 19 alors que les éléphants sont
menacés dans d'autres pays au zimbabwe
leur nombre explose ils sont cent mille
l'argent généré par la vente d'ivoire à
peu près 600 millions de dollars pour et
aider à gérer ces pachydermes
mais pour des pays comme le kenya la
tanzanie la vente d'ivoire est
impensable elle ferait repartir le
braconnage qui a décimé leurs troupeaux
une vente va relancer le marché noir et
les braconniers vendrait des défenses de
rhinocéros et d'éléphants
c'est un très grand danger pour nos
espèces
le zimbabwe a besoin de solution à son
problème d'éléphant
tous les ans les animaux tu des dizaines
de personnes gérer leurs populations en
déplacer une partie par exemple vers
d'autres pays prend du temps et beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
dans l'est de la république démocratique
du congo des combats ont éclaté mardi
avant une vingtaine de kilomètres au
nord de goma selon des témoignages
d'habitants des tirs d'armé lourde ont
été entendus vers 3 heures du matin
certaines sources affirment que des
rebelles du m23 ont attaqué une position
militaire dotera culte et rwandais
d'avoir participé aux combats des
centaines de civils ont fui je vous
propose d'écouter ces quelques réactions
micro de justin kalumba
nous sommes en train de fuir la guerre
qui a eu lieu à cuba depuis deux heures
déplaçons parce qu'on nous a dit de vie
des deux villages nous demandant
président félix et qui dit de nous aider
savoir où nous avons trouvé réfuge
cependant car nous avons tout perdu ces
derniers ont depuis longtemps nous
congolais nous sommes fatigués de la
guerre nos enfants meurent nos maris
sont tués nous avons tout perdu et nous
sommes restés pauvres regardez en eux
cultivent plus longs champs car nous
fuyons chaque fois que le président
tshisekedi fasse tout pour dialoguer
avec son homologue pour que les gens ne
meurent plus et que la paix revienne
donc on peut confirmer sans avoir peur
d'être contredit que c'est le rwanda qui
soutient les 23 pour le moment parce
qu'il m'aime vitres avaient tous deux
fait et il n'aurait plus la force de
venir attaquer nos voiliers phare de ces
on peut déjà confirmer que le rwanda est
déjà derrière cette attaque et nous
condamnons avec la dernière énergie
et la rdc souhaite se hisser parmi les
premiers exportateurs de pétrole du
continent le pays dispose d'importants
gisements dans son sous-sol et le
gouvernement va lancer en juillet un
appel d'offres pour l'exploitation de 16
blocs pétroliers avec à la clé pas moins
de 650 milliards de dollars au prix
actuel du baril elle didier boudy m'bow
ministre des hydrocarbures était mon
invité il a réagi à cette flambée de
violence dans la région où doit être
exploité non loin de là un bloc
pétrolier écoutez sa réaction
apprendre des choses c'est que le
gouvernement suivant la vision du chef
de l'état a déjà décrété c'est qu'on
appelle l'état d'urgence pour essayer de
régler ces histoires et c'est de là que
nous voyons que ont en tête de découvrir
ceux qui sont ennemis du peuple
congolais mais déjà je peux vous
rassurer qu'au niveau du lac kivu n'y a
pas de violence il ya aucun problème
parce que l'exploitation qui est au
niveau du lac kivu même juste en face au
niveau du rwanda ils sont en train
d'exploiter et nous allons commencer
bientôt avec les 70 66 me sur 1,6
milliard de da nau matricule que nous
avons en termes de gaz méthane dont je
pense que c'est le moment de pouvoir
lancer ses activités de pouvoir
exploiter notre gaz mais cet état
d'urgence à un an maintenant on a fait
le bilan ya pas très longtemps et
populations locales demandent à voir
plus de résultats résultats vont venir
on le sait tous qu'il ya des gars qui
ont duré plus que ça mais la volonté est
là la volonté du gouvernement la volonté
du chef de l'état la vente de notre
armée parce que je pense qu'il ya
quelques jours ils ont pu répondre les
collines de l'autre côté donc ça veut
dire que nous sommes dans le bon et je
sais qu'on va finir par y arriver
monsieur le ministre c'est 16 blocs
pétroliers représentent un peu plus de
600 milliards de dollars combien iront
dans les caisses de l'état la totalité
totalité paso d'idées n'est pas que nous
puissions que les gens puissent enrichir
le à bavois de des richesses
personnelles l'idée est de pouvoir
réhausser le niveau de l'économie
nationale au niveau de niveaux de la vie
des populations et parlera pas par
rapport à ça je peux donner l'exemple de
au mois de décembre nous avons signé
l'avènement 9 par rapport à la
valorisation du gaz y était que j'ai été
brûlé au niveau de me demande à ce gaz
associés dont on a entendu l'ancien avec
le neuf avec eux associés perenco les
caisses de l'état n'ont plus gagné que
25 millions de dollars mais le chef de
l'état avait décidé il a décidé que dans
ces 25 minutes de la dîme urbain de
aller directement la population locale
chose qui est en train d'être fait pour
que cette population locale puisse en
bénéficier
donc je pense que la population le
peuple d'abord est mis en avant perenco
elle est déjà présente dans le pays
c'est même un géant et l'entreprise est
mise en cause pour des atteintes graves
à l'environnement et à la santé des
populations
elle a même refusé de se soumettre à la
loi française perenco qui est notre seul
partenaire qui exploite actuellement ça
fait des années je pense que la perenco
exploite par rapport
convention en 2009 169 parce qu'ils ont
eu à rester où je pense aux prêts d'ici
de chez vous mais actuellement il ya loi
de 2015 dont je viens de parler et le dk
2016 c'est sur ça que va être régi les
contrats de partage de production qui
seront signés dont les jours les mois à
venir donc on se serait sinistre soit
perenco que ce soit chez vont que ce
soit aux tables tout le monde va être
soumis à ces qui sera aux règles que
nous avons mis mon père une fois n'est
pas exclue non personne et est ce que
malgré les accusations ces appels
d'offres sont ouverts par le père
reconnaît pas su pas ce que vous voulez
en confiance il en quoi c'est dû aux
enfants sinon quoi c'est dur en
angleterre vous tant qu'ils sont cons là
pourquoi nous envoie les est ce que s'il
sortirait des attentats la population
est la santé des populaires les attentes
à l'environnement des attentats la seule
de ses racines est dans le nom ce
contrat de partage de production va
protéger la population et sa vie va
permettre à la population de pouvoir
être protégés de pouvoir avoir accès
comment dire à la formation donc
pourquoi est ce qu'il n'ya pas déçu tout
le monde les appels d'offres sont
ouverts à tout le monde nous attendons
l'arrivée tout le monde une interview à
retrouver en intégralité sur notre site
internet voilà c'est la fin du journal
de l'afrique merci de votre fidélité à
rester avec nous l'information continue
[Musique]